[Music]
hey everyone welcome to simulation we
are now sitting down with Z cos over
hello hi nice to talk with you thanks
for coming on the show thank you
appreciate it
z can i first met when we were doing
thinkers and raters fun show we were
doing that like four months ago now
there's a good show I'm marginally more
sober now Zeke was crushing it you were
answering the questions we had really
tough and diverse questions across
different categories and you were and
you were answering them and you had good
things to say and teach about it well so
I'm a big fan of pub quiz so I
appreciate the pub quiz oriented science
questions and but one of the things
about being a high school I was a high
school science teacher for twenty-one
years and the you have to end up
teaching essentially every science
discipline so if you're gonna ask
questions like things you were supposed
to learn in school as a science student
that's the stuff I'm supposed to know
yeah well how does a rainbow work and
like why don't I land water mixes like
all this kind of stuff is equal be like
I have the answer I can be particularly
a know-it-all if you give me a half a
chance
so Zeke for the background he is the
co-director and teacher have the
leadership program at the teacher
Institute at the Exploratorium I've been
doing that for four years now yes
awesome and then also before that ten
years as the dean of math and science at
the Jewish Community High School at the
bay and then also an Einstein
distinguished fellow educator fellow yes
which is awesome
that got to go to DC for a year and give
advice to our our government but the
executive and legislative branch about
science education yep they didn't pay
terribly a lot of attention to me but it
was a chance to see government up close
and personal [ __ ] you up there it's like
I can help us teach our children science
and they're like listen we have some
wars to fight and so now yeah let's do
this a nature of learning and just the
the importance of this knowing how to
teach and teach others how to teach well
to to the youth to get them to care more
about science and to care more about the
world around them in that sense and also
there's all these different learning
styles so that complicates things alive
I have some choice things to say about
learning styles but we can we can save
that for a little bit I want to hear
them so I mean so there's little to no
evidence that there are particular
styles that you learn best at so like
there are some things that are taught
better one way or another so if I want
to teach like the let's say how how
forces interact to make a building able
to stand up if I didn't draw you
pictures of the building and show you
lines and and do that in a visual way
that'd be a lot harder on the other hand
if I'm teaching about how sound works in
waves and I don't use auditory things
I'm wasting an opportunity so they're
different topics can be taught different
ways in some ways better than others but
we also have preferences of like the
ways we like to learn yeah so some of us
like to read and some of us like to
listen and some of us like to see people
dance their PhDs which is a fantastic
set of videos you should see but it
turns out that that is there's been tons
of research on them with thousands and
thousands of students and it turns out
that that is largely unimportant like
what a student thinks is their preferred
learning style what some test that they
have taken that says that they learn
best in a visual way or there's just
little evidence that they actually do
learn better
now it is true that we are happier when
we have our preferences being fulfilled
so if we like to be taught in a visual
way and we're being taught in a visual
way we'll certainly be happier and learn
more from that mm-hmm
but it doesn't necessarily mean we will
learn more the teacher should rather
than trying to like pick the learning
styles that their students they should
be picking with a method of instruction
that best teaches the material exactly
and so it's the material that needs to
be pegged and then students need to
learn how to interpret all the different
kinds so everything from how to look at
graphs and understand things visually to
how to listen to a story and then how to
make how to use a story to help them
remember information better and all the
ways to like how did I handle equipment
and so how that the the interaction with
with the actual physical world helps you
learn things so all of those need to be
put in together and they need to be
based on what's the most useful thing to
teach that particular topic and I know
that I've gone into this you will get
thousands of comments saying that I
don't have any idea what I'm talking
about in terms of learning styles
because every kid for about the last 10
years has been tested on it but there is
tremendous the body of research is quite
large
I actually agree a lot with what you're
saying especially as someone that tries
that sits across from these diverse
scientists and entrepreneurs working on
all these different styles of projects
and then as I actively listen to them
and paraphrase what they say to make it
relatable I'm doing exactly what you
just said which is if they're if they're
explaining something a certain way then
they're doing it because they already
know that that is a way that relates
more with the general audience and so
like you said you're making a building
you've got to show how the building
stands up visually if you're learning
about sound it helps a lot to actually
pure the sound through your senses it's
like different senses get activated when
it doesn't even make sense to try and
explain yet sorry is they is the
lavalier transmitter next to somebody
cellphone Oh interesting it is actually
thank you no it's a it does interfere
with he had call we can put it down here
okay sorry about that no worries no
worries that's a that's a good catch Rob
yeah what what and just out of curiosity
what is do you know what occurs is it uh
if he's getting taxed or if the phone is
ringing and vibrating it's just it you
can hear the he wasn't it wasn't
actually vibrating it might still it
might maybe got it yeah it could be just
yeah the proximity of the two can create
static yes that's so interesting didn't
know that that's good to know for future
sorry your Dan we have any idea how much
money that just cost I our corporate
sponsors are gonna be pissed that was
actually a good learning it's funny
we're talking about learning and then we
have a cell phone next to an actual
receiver for the transmitter for audio
so that's that's interesting others
there's interference between those two
okay so back at so the acts are the way
that you teach material depending on the
material is more important to because
you're trying to get it to general
masses right then it is to personalize
to every single student well so I don't
want to get that I don't want to have
that quite strongly a generalization I
will say that some things personalized
very well to each individual student and
other things don't so yeah an example of
this is that one of the strongest things
you can get student to learn makes help
student learn something is to have them
be invested in the answer and so there's
been a lot of interesting research on
this front which is that
so if you show a student a demonstration
even a very dramatic demonstration like
you could show them that two objects of
different masses you can let them fall
to the ground and you can set it up with
electromagnets to release them at
exactly the same time and then have
high-speed cameras so that they can see
it in class them hit at the same time
and then ask them a few weeks later
which mass will hit the ground first
some of those students will say the
heavy one will hit the ground first even
though they've seen in class with the
high-speed camera the two objects hit at
the same time and you might say so like
how can that be like why would they like
you know they just saw this great
demonstration well it turns out that
most the time kids are really passive in
class even though you've you've been a
lot of work to make this complicated
demonstration the students just like
sitting back on yeah yeah I've heard
that before
but then when you ask them on the test
what happened they'll say I saw the
heavy work everyone will hit will hit
first and how do you know and yes and
the question they'll say because I saw
that in class a couple weeks ago even
though they saw exactly not that and so
having students become invested in the
process is very important and one of
those ways you can do that is you can
have students make predictions ask them
ahead of time what do you think is gonna
happen make them write it down make them
send it to the teacher some way okay and
then if you do that then students will
get a better result and because we
really actually personalized this
experience for that student they are
involved they've skin in the game yeah
this seems to Lev skin in the game
actly and it's it's important for
everybody including students and then
you can get even more skin in the game
later on it's after they have some
experience with some of the things
you're trying to ves Kate you ask the
students what what experiment would you
like to see next what do you think is
gonna happen I come up with your own
idea for something to do and in a big
lecture class of 75 or 100 students
that's tough to do their ideas but in a
high school classroom with middle school
classroom with 30 kids in it you can
have their suggestions and then try
those things out and see what they learn
from them and that really gets kids
involved and then when you're involved
then you want to learn and you
understand and that's incredibly
personalized that's a lot more
personalized than saying I'm just gonna
do this visually for the visual students
and auditorially for the auger tutorials
oh yeah for the audio bass students no
there's like I will curious what will
happen when you do this and then you do
that and find out what happens oh I'm
liking where you're going right now
there's these there's these almost these
best principles for getting students
invested into the knowledge that they're
learning right and so one of the ways
you said was to have them make a
hypothesis on what's gonna happen that
gets them invested into the outcome
they're trying to be like did I guess
that right or was that what was I wrong
why was that wrong maybe another way is
one of my favorite ways of teaching kids
about gravity is the trampoline with the
weights mm-hmm I love that educational
piece it was so fascinating cuz the
trampolines the fabric of space-time and
then the larger piece of mass was in the
middle as the star and then the throw
the marbles around as the planets
orbiting and I just thought that was
such a good example so then if the
students are the ones that also actually
get their hands on the practice that can
help a lot as well right so in addition
to just like showing them what happens
with it you'll say to a student well
let's say I have another another large
mass in the middle and so you have sort
of two depressions and the fabric and
you can ask the students to try to guess
what will happen now and so they work
that for a while so they have some
feeling for the system how it's a model
what its limitations are as a model a
little bit in the maze and say now what
questions you have about how this
how do you think this is connected to
what actually happens and then students
will say oh I wonder what happens if
they're three that's pretty
straightforward and then someone will
say but what if they're like two right
on top of each other how is that
different than two separated and then
you'll say I don't know but you know the
answer to every question it's an
experiment let's try it and see what
happens
mm-hmm see what other best practices do
you pass along to other teachers that
are especially you you you you get you
work with a lot of teachers that are
just starting to teach right right so
the the hardest thing for new teachers
actually it's hard for all of us not
just new teachers is when we learn it
especially when there's like 40 kids
packed into it there are definitely some
principals and some school board members
that I'd like to have long conversations
with about why you've set things up this
way but in any case we can't control
that part I can't control that part but
what you when one of the hard parts for
teachers is our for any of us is
understanding what it takes to make
sense of some phenomenon so you can't
just tell people that it works this way
like that doesn't convince people it
doesn't change the way they see the
world those sort of mental models we
already have in our head about what's
happening and so you have to figure out
what are all the different ideas that
you'd have to be convinced about before
you could even begin to start putting
all the ideas together to have a new
mental model about how the world works
and so one of the things we spend a lot
of time working with new teachers is
having them look at some particular
topic like maybe they want to teach
students about air pressure for example
what do you need to know to be able to
sort out the ideas of air pressure well
you need to know that inside this
invisible stuff here there are there's
stuff actually there there's actually
little additives of nitrogen and oxygen
yeah there's actually little bits of
things here you have to convince them
that they're moving around you have to
convince them that they move around
faster when they're hotter and less fast
when they're cooler that when they
collide with things they can push on
them and that those pushing is what we
call pressure like they're all and you
need and to to really teach it well you
have to sit down with all these
different things that you have to teach
and you have to figure out then what's
an activity what's a way to convince the
skeptical child yeah and if they have
any sense they'll be skeptical because
they learn lots of things it's cool yeah
true so they definitely be skeptical um
how you convince a child about each one
of these ideas and then figuring out
what order to do these activities in can
be challenging as well in some ways only
through experience can you achieve
enlightenment can you figure it out you
have to try different things but you put
these activities together then too so
that the students have this experience
that this is the way the world works you
don't just have to trust me yeah and
then you help them make sense of all
these ideas and build this new mental
model and that's a multi-step process
you have to figure out all these little
bits and put them together I really
enjoy the way that you're explaining
it's like the mind is this like tableau
so this will this blank stage it's worse
than that it's full of wrong thing it's
full of wrong things the first step you
have to do is convince people that um
actually I say it's full wrong these
it's not true it's actually it's
actually full of lots of ideas most of
which are true yeah but some of them are
not true like that's why science has to
come about we didn't yeah I'm into the
world and I mean our ancestors didn't
come into the world already knowing how
the world worked they were full of what
worked well at the time for the amount
of knowledge that they needed to have at
that moment but as we get more
sophisticated and have more
sophisticated systems and we discover
that some of the things the ways we
think the world works aren't true they
don't pass our mental models and so
we're like whoa whoa that didn't happen
the way I expected I need to figure out
how to I need to figure out what's
really
happening and that's something that this
we want our students to do as well
because then that's what will change
their mental model so that then they can
reshape it to a new idea and that's why
it's so hard that's why you can't just
because they don't come in table right
they came in not knowing anything you
could just tell them this is the way it
works yeah yeah they come in with
incorrect interpretations which makes it
more difficult to teach as well so it's
almost as though this is something that
we speak about quite a bit on the show
is this notion that when a child's birth
into the world that it is then the
responsibility of the parent and of the
community of the teachers of of the
social fabric in general to help that
child gain some sort of a objective
understanding of the world that they
live in and then also to have a path of
actualization to bring value to the
world and to find meaning and all this
kind of stuff and so the idea of all
these different ways of helping mold
that child's mind through these
strategies that have been practiced for
long periods of time is is crucial you
like you described the child must have
an example of how to learn about
pressure and how to learn there's
actually thing things here and then the
child must learn about how well if I
tell you that the water has a certain
molecular composition or that this glass
was made 5,000 glasses were made 5,000
years ago there have got to be ways for
the child to better understand that
through pictures maybe of very old
ancient photos maybe of of the
composition of water through actual
diagrams of h2o and it's Andres so
there's and then how do they get to to
play with it to break it down themselves
there's maybe they make a pottery
themselves of a glass well so certainly
I mean for what water is a students not
doing electrolysis in class and
discovering that you can you break down
water with electric electricity into
hydrogen and oxygen and then in one test
tube you'll get twice as much hydrogen
as you get oxygen and the other tube and
then if you combine them together you
make an ear-splitting explosion but you
get drops of water afterwards
like that stuff like that's an
experience that will teach you a topic
that I mean it mitad leme almost all of
us know that water is h2o but it's taken
many of us you know we had to get taught
this over and over and over here before
we understood and believed that was true
we could have been had our students do
the science that the science tissa
actually actually did or simplified
versions of it or ones where they don't
have to go down although the wrong paths
that didn't work out very well so that
they can have a chance to do some of
these activities and they can learn a
lot out of it and they both learn
something about the nature of science
and it's more memorable and it'll stay
with them okay how about we ask you what
are some of the other best practices
that you've learned I know you've been
teaching us about some so far they're
super interesting
what are ones that really resonate with
teachers and and/or students well
students students really like stories as
well and so that leads some people than
when they want to teach science to teach
it as this historical document I did get
a degree in the history of science and
so it's super interesting to me um the
problem is is that most of the
historical stories are kind of not true
like we oversimplify them so that people
have a tough time really like
understanding that science like goes the
wrong way a lot and then has to
backtrack when they discover that no
that idea isn't actually enough and we
teach science always being very linear
where multiple paths are actually
happening all at the same time one of
them will be resolved but students can
make their own sort of stories about not
the history of science but the
particular problem that they're
interested in you can teach through
having students do projects so
project-based science works great but
also just some sort of storyline so for
example many years ago when I was teach
in New Orleans there was a with New
Orleans of streetcars and an
intersection and it turns out that
students who were just learning to drive
at the same time they were taking my
physics class would discover that they
we get caught in this intersection all
the time and it was very scary because
the streetcars had the right-of-way and
they come up very close to them and try
to frighten them off the tracks and that
would make them jump across the street
and sometimes they'd get into car
accidents terrible and so one of my
students had that hypothesis the idea
that that the yellow light was the wrong
length of time hmm so we were teaching
about accelerations we were teaching
about braking safe how fast can you
safely brake how what's the speed limit
of the street and we could then sit down
and would measure the street we measured
the size of the intersection how fast
cars were typically going what the
actual speed limit was how fast cars
could stop and we did some of our own
research on that but we also were happy
to use car and driver which lists the
best braking speed they used to list I
don't know if they still do but used to
listed like the best braking speed of
all the production cars and then
students had a problem that they wanted
to solve um
we're interested in getting the data
right for it and they essentially had a
story cuz they could each one made up
their own story of like when they were
going through that intersection and how
dangerous or scary it was and how maybe
we could make that just a little bit
better and so for the first time
students were super interested in like
understanding acceleration right and
that's fantastic when that happens they
take on the project for themselves yeah
there's a there's these usually story
moments for kids when they realized that
their story in everyday life has to do
with science and math and I remember
hearing from people for the last couple
of years I'm not good at math and then I
and then I you'd this might one of my
first examples is well you know when
you're walking across the street and the
lights about to
to turn you know you're calculating six
five four and you're and you're in the
process of starting across the street
you then are running a complicated math
problem in your head you're like okay I
can either stay back or I can pick up
speed by about three miles an hour so
that I can cross the street before the
signal ends so that the cars can go and
they're like oh that's that's math and
I'm like yeah that's math and you're
doing it without even knowing that
you're doing it and even it's either
more simple things like even tips ten
percent move the decimal you're like so
so I hope you're doing more than ten
percent yeah temp temp remove the
decimal times - all right then there's
the Tauri
there's your twenty yeah
okay so then okay let's let's ask about
this because I think you'll have a good
perspective on this what what what is
the ideal environment for a teacher and
kids teachers are first of all they're
just very under loved and
underappreciated in today's world but
also we need to have you know really
strong teachers in in those positions if
teachers are paid more and we review
them more often and then people would be
more excited to be teachers etc we could
end up having a really stronger system
okay now what is this ideal environment
and also where do kind of like where did
the where does the philosophy of
teaching come into into into play here
we've all kind of been talking about it
a little bit but we probably shouldn't
be a teacher to 40 kids it should
probably be a teacher to maybe 20 kids
and then should they be specializing in
just science and teaching just science
for 20 years or should they be a little
more broad what do you do your thoughts
so class sizes should definitely be
smaller and teachers should have the
resources so that they have time to
prepare their lessons they should have
the physical resources to be able to do
lab experiments in class and do the
experiments in class and the
Terrell's so that group sizes can be
sufficiently small that everyone can get
their hands on the equipment watching
someone else do science is science isn't
a spectator sport
do it yourself at least as much as
possible some things might be a little
too dangerous we wouldn't want every kid
maybe blowing up the hydrogen balloon
but but we want to have enough materials
to go around so that each lab group can
do the experiments and then we actually
don't want it so small and you actually
don't really want kids by themselves
because for many kids talking it out
with someone else helps them make the
connections that they're looking for as
most of us know that working on teams
helps us figure things out better than
usually there are some people for whom
by themselves as best but for most of us
working with someone else helps us
figure out what we're really thinking
and tests us and doesn't let us keep our
dumb assumptions they'll say things like
that doesn't make any sense I don't know
what you're talking about and so those
are the things that we are so those are
all the things that teachers need know
I've you I've taught I taught history as
well as science and I've taught a little
bit of math as well and I ended up
teaching a lot of science disciplines
but I don't necessarily think that
that's the best path for a person
teaching science is a different
discipline because of all the lab
experiences that I think students should
have and that takes a lot of time to
learn so I would say that teaching
science I don't want to put add any
extra burdens on teachers besides having
to teach science okay so to do class
size smaller also help with these best
practices get them out into the world
now okay I want to ask you a question
about the what what would be an ideal if
we were to create a volume one of
knowledge
let's say if we were to create volume
one of knowledge what would be written
in this book and and what year could a
child learn what your could have parents
start teaching their child this volume
one of knowledge I mean it's sort of a
complicated question I'll say that you
know the process skills are what you
would want to start with the youngest
kids learning how to observe the world
learning how to ask questions of it and
do experiments to see what actually
turns out and learning to trust what you
learned by experiment is a way of
thinking about the world like
interesting your own senses then they
aren't trying so you do sometimes lie to
you but they're trying to lie to you
I think that those are all the places
that you would start with younger kids
and then younger kids are pretty smart
they can actually handle quite a lot I
wouldn't start with calculus in fourth
grade but start doing
we have intuitive number sense students
can start learning about numbers and one
of our groups the group I work with only
works with the middle and high school
teachers but we have another group at
the Exploratorium called the Institute
for inquiry that works with elementary
school teachers and they have activities
that start with with like figuring out
what causes shadows what happens if you
have multiple light sources or an
extended light source or instead of like
point sources of light like a
fluorescent tube should come teach that
at the studio like lighting in a studio
is a part of that kind of trial for
example you have you have six lights and
a big skylight in here yeah yeah you
have multiple lights because you could
just say well why have why have a bunch
of lights when I have to one or two
bright lights and of course it has to do
with shadows and as when you get older
you understand that especially when you
get in the business but when I first
started doing some you know I was you
know teachers going to videotape my
classroom and so I just got big light on
top of my projector my camera and I you
know spent a couple weeks taking
terrible videos because I didn't
understand that that would test test
harsh shadows on everything else but you
know an elementary school student not
only can figure that out with some you
know instruction some activities set up
for them they can become really
sophisticated and understanding that
understanding like where shadows come
from and why some shadows are darker
than other shadows and even why an
eclipse like some parts see part of the
Sun and once that is perfectly that's
perfectly within their abilities ok so
let's say that we're starting to teach a
child about perception and analyzing
their environment and then running tests
and then being able to secure that as
knowledge or not as knowledge because
they haven't tested enough etc ok so
that's that's the perception layer now
here here would be a question to ask you
that I think you'll find interesting
something that I've started to say a lot
on this show is the idea of objective
truth being a very important
foundational layer for civilization if
we if we lack objective truth we can get
into a very like post modernist sort of
everybody disagrees on everything sort
of understanding of things and that's
that's not good we need some sort of
objective truth so for example we were
talking about the molecular composition
of water or maybe we're talking about
gravity at the surface of the earth or
maybe we're talking about the earth
being a sphere or that it orbits the
star so here are these or maybe your
heart that beats a hundred thousand
times ish per day that keeps you alive
okay so we just listed a couple of these
objective truths now now would you say
that it's important to get these kind of
fundamental pillars of truth to young
children
I'm sure and I think that I think
they'll be more meaningful for them if
they get them through experience yes so
like it's if you want to you know figure
out how many times your heart beats per
day is an interesting multi like is a
way to teach multiplication if it is a
hard addition problem mmm you know 3,600
seconds per hour makes that a you know
challenging just try to actually start
counting them out that way you know you
want multiplication then yeah but you
can a student like it's better to have
them sort of figure out how many times
their heart beats in a minute and then
multiply multiply yeah like that's it's
not hard yeah rather than me telling
them that I mean the same thing with
like you know that the earth is round I
mean it is objectively round I think the
evidence very strongly points to that
but if they can strap on like VR and
look from the International Space
Station down at Earth maybe something
like that could be I might help
although figuring out like why it seems
flat but we actually people thousands of
years ago that it was round like that is
a like helping students like how that
same revelatory moment I think is really
worth it rather than trying to beat into
someone's head yeah it's round because
so for fun and you know this is the
Exploratorium doing physics shows I
thought that in the age of YouTube no
one would want to see physics shows
anymore but it turns out that a lot of
people want physical minute physics that
does really well on you what's really
interesting bit about minute I mean men
in physics does terribly well yeah and
so I thought the people like who would
be showing like physics demonstrations
on YouTube would kill the local physics
show business can we come and why watch
someone do a physical experience design
right there and funny yeah so people
still people still fill the halls
because some physics shows even though
they can see them better and more
close-up on YouTube in their boxers
exactly in a hot tub you know there are
there are there are times and places to
really do physics and but they but
because we actually live in a world
where it's so easy to manipulate him
I think they actually believed them last
now I think YouTube's actually yeah like
it was creating a stronger desire for
hands-on knowledge yes and places like
science museums like the Exploratorium
where you have a chance to try out and
learn knowledge through experience like
I think it's really becoming even more
important place because whereas VR like
you could like they could ease just as
easily show you through the goggles that
the world really is flat with giant
holes like scattered among it and that's
no no no but I mean you could do it and
you could show whatever you'd like
uh-huh through it and so that I think I
mean at first we just believe everything
we see but as we become more mature we
start to wonder whether we can believe
anything that we say and so I think that
there's a lot of interest for people to
going back to like I need to have a
directly experience through my own
senses through my hands eyes and ears
I like how you called it the revelatory
experience that it needs to be hands-on
experience revealed to you that even
though a couple even hundred years ago
it was like oh are we gonna sail off of
the side of the earth no one has
believed that at least in the West since
about 500 BC like don't one [ __ ]
Columbus was going to see hell up in the
debate was whether how big the earth
would be you knew you were gonna pray
yeah like not that the earth was flat
but how big it was he was wrong I do
think if you hadn't run into North
America he would have starved to death
which arguably might have been okay but
but could the rest of the planet just be
an ocean right that's just one piece I
think it could be couldn't be and so
then he thought that people had
calculated the earth it's being too
large of the earth was actually much
smaller do you think there are
undiscovered islands no you think we've
discovered everything no we don't know
anything about the bottom of the bottom
of the ocean yeah we know far more about
Mars than we know
yeah it's like the Mariana Trench is
like 37,000 feet deep or something like
that it's like crazy but we haven't
exhibited the Exploratorium it is not a
physics exhibit despite the fact they
teach physics but it's my favorite
exhibit in the building
it's a plate that we keep under the bay
under the water and it stays under the
water for several weeks and then it's
brought up and put into a sealed
cylinder and we have some cameras that
look at it and you can zoom the cameras
around you can look closely at this
plate and the plate is full of monsters
and things that you've never seen before
even though I look at it every day and I
worked there for years I still see on
every plate something new that I've
never seen before and this plate just
lives for several weeks just under the
Exploratorium in the water Wow and it's
full of things that are completely I
mean I'm not a marine biologist maybe
it's not completely new to marine
biology but Moses walk around having no
idea what's happening at just an all
surface of the water totally what are
some of the things that you discovered
on the plate so first off I've seen
barnacles before I've gone sailing but
I've always seen barnacles all closed up
because they're out of the water turns
out they open up and have giant feather
like appendages that go out that look
like there's actually no horror monsters
that look as nasty as the the feathery
appendages it's like grabbing things out
of the water and trying to pull it into
this horrible mouth like device there
are I've seen two shrimp tear each tear
each other's arms off whoa I mean
fighting over territory food I yeah I
wasn't sure yeah yeah there's there once
a little tiny crab got in there and it
was just like running rampage everything
yeah it's okay so the but the plate you
only see it once you take it out right
okay and then once you take it out and
how do you it's so it's got a it's got a
little cylinder so like continues to
circulate water in it so it's it's so
the plate is like it's still under the
water except it's now in a little
cylinder like this but you were
capturing the video all right what's
going on in oh you were capturing the
video was going on throughout the period
of time no no just no just for this like
week that we've taken it out of the
water and then we'll put it back in
yeah okay and capture it for that week
though or no no it I'm sorry I've done a
terrible job of explaining so like that
we have a whole series there like six or
seven of them that live under the bang
and we pull one up and put it into a
special refrigerated box that flows
water over it but now inside the
Exploratorium so that people can look at
the plate and then - and it's more like
a cylinder I suppose because it has
water flowing over the top of it so that
creatures in there it's sort of like
it's still under the water and then we
have some excellent cameras that can
look in on the so that you can really
see up close - what's all the life
that's happening there I like how we
were talking about the insanity of 95%
of the ocean that remains unexplored
it's crazy I remember seeing that video
I think it was off the coast of Japan of
that like massive octopus that came by
or it was a squid one of the disease
with a Lhasa also squid just think they
ran out of adjectives after a while yeah
yeah he's had colossal like sight but
yeah they came by just massive huge
being I just that that's one of the -
I'd like to ask you this question but
one of the - for me for the question of
what animal would you choose to be
I like eagle I like flying and then I
also like this octopus or squid these
massive underwater creatures so I can go
and explore down there what about you
I've always thought about becoming a I
actually in the few seconds you've asked
me but now I've always been afraid of
Humboldt squid they're the squid that
live out in the ocean and have recently
started showing up off the California
coast they're about six feet long and in
addition to suckers they also have giant
hooks oh yeah and they're smart enough
to figure out like the hoses that divers
need to stay alive and they're like take
off divers masks knowing that then they
can't see under the water so that's
scary yeah I think I actually I think
there's an excellent science fiction
novel out there about how squid and
octopus figure out that humans are
destroying the ocean have decided to
take over the sea and we don't get to go
back into the ocean
we don't the act they like they see the
Pacific Garbage Patch and they're like
we're gonna we're taking care of these
human people I mean we're just lucky
that they I mean they they have very
different brains than arts in some think
quite differently than I survived I
presume but they live relatively short
lives so octa-pie octa-pie they live for
in five years so they sort if they lived
long lives like us and we're social like
us they aren't very social I'm thinking
long research octopus really live a
short life they have short lives even
the real big ones that you see I believe
even giant octopi live short lives oh
all right I used to feel bad because you
know I like octopus and but now I feel
less bad you shouldn't feel this bad
they're very smart
yeah well that's the thing you know
that's why now I'm don't really like I
feel bad because I eat them because
they're a smart creature and you know
just the whole living thing searching
virgins deserve it but okay how about
how about you give us another area or
two that is super fascinating to you I'm
really interested in the nature of
perception like how do we you know we
you know the weed that we think of is
actually you know a bunch of goo in the
centre of my head maybe I'll include the
spinal column a little bit with it as
well and do you think that we is
centralized to this nervous system yeah
it's it's located right here and the
weed does not exist outside of this area
right here so far I have not found
evidence that I call it arising okay
okay I mean continue I I will agree to
the limitation of my knowledge yeah yeah
okay so perception but that are those
limits on our perception so for example
I'm colorblind
and so I don't perceive colors the same
way that other people do
and so I have to take sort of people's
word for it that there are other you
know that these two colors look
different when they look the same to me
and I just wonder what other sort of
limits of our perceptions mean that
there are things that are around us that
we are aren't able to perceive but what
Z's not telling you is that he can see
an infrared you could do you have
infrared sensors all over your face like
little so you don't have you don't have
lenses for them so you don't have a you
don't have like so pit vipers have
essentially pinhole cameras for him for
red we have of course lenses for visible
light but yeah but you actually have
infrared sensors on your face if you
take something that's hot like that got
a Kindle flame yeah and you close your
eyes and have someone else hold it in
front of your face you can find you can
know it's a general fascinating you can
put them blind fold seeing for sure
can't see don't like yeah yeah you can
feel the placement of it you not nearly
as precisely as you can with vision not
even close to that but you do have
sensors on on your face so that you can
find I can be bad to run into something
to talk agree are similarly to our skin
though where we take like a candle and
put it here we can still sense it sure
in fact it's more per eye pretty sure
that your face actually has much better
heat sensors than your hands I was
working with a glass blower a while ago
and he was fond of saying over and over
to when we were trying to do some glass
work that hot glass looks exactly the
same as cold glass and so what he would
do is he would pick up the the hot glass
with his pair of tongs and hold it in
front of his face to see if it was cool
rather than like touching it with his
hand first and burning his hand he says
you know whoa
yeah that's a good point you know he
said you didn't like that's how you can
tell yep yep so okay so the limits of
our perception so you know david
eagleman 'he's work yeah as well yes so
this is really interesting we can
augment our human senses in order to
explore more of the world around us
where does he where do you stand in the
augmentation like what are your
interests in it you were just talking
about it ooh our 15-minute timer thank
you Ron
flip that up alright that's a we have
our graphic coming back yeah yeah that's
all good I was thinking maybe you were
gonna pull up like the giant squid or
like the Mariana Trench we should get we
should get better at that though over
time I'm just experimenting whatever
this machine can do and I sorry that no
let's do that though for the future ones
I'll be cool to pull up the different
graphics yes yeah yeah without a doubt
yeah good idea yeah yeah imposed ah yeah
we're working working on figuring out
how to make the shows exceptional yeah
right now there yeah we need to talk to
the finance officer I find the budget to
do that by the budget exactly we're
working on it
visit us on patreon to help us with this
yeah that's right that's right
okay so continue with senses and
presumption so a few years ago I went to
an event where a guy had put a bracelet
on our anklet bracelet on his ankle and
at first when we saw them and then I was
like oh my god I wonder what he did that
he has to be under the house arrest
breaker Anglian um but no no what he had
done was he had put a magnetic field
sensor hall-effect probes on it so he
you know electronic device they knew
which direction was north and then he
had a very small vibrating thing I've
heard about this yeah it would always be
just very gently vibrating against his
ankle and he said that at first he like
detected he felt the vibration but after
a while that vibration like had sort of
faded away I mean he could refocus in on
it but it mostly just sort of knew what
direction North was and then when he was
in a building that had big iron walls
and things like that that screwed up
yeah finding magnetic or attacked but he
felt he said he'd feel disoriented and
it would take him a while to realize in
what way he was feeling disoriented from
it and so I think that it's probably
possible to add
since I think our brand is sufficiently
plastic that we could probably add
additional senses just to to the to our
existence yeah I'm not sure what ones
we'd want because I feel like I'm we're
already like magnetic main
electromagnetic is electric like static
electric field or relatively static and
relatively static magnetic fields we are
we have no senses for it so I think it's
amazing that we found them at all
they're actually yeah but I wonder what
other things like we could detect like I
always imagined like what would we like
to be a dog and like to have this
chemical sensor that's telling you so
much more information about the room
that I have nothing about those slits on
the nose just so much snow yeah yeah
exactly what would it would be like to
be a dolphin and what it would be like
yeah just I just I just want and I want
to feel that those senses we're gonna
get there we're gonna get there soon how
we do it it's very difficult but we're
gonna we're slowly gonna get their
physique okay couple simulation
questions for you on our way out how
about we ask you as we become a more
globalized world and when we look at
Earth from the moon
there's no borders but when we talk
about economic and political issues we
definitely talk about borders and stuff
how do we work together as a planet and
progress and prosper well I think that
the I mean I'm no expert I mean I know a
lot about teaching I don't know a lot
about this so we pull people into these
new domains of thought to some of my
gases are is that the hard part
the hardest part of that is actually
figuring out what the goals are like the
things that I want the world that I
think and make the world a better place
I'm not sure everyone in the world would
agree with me on that
free abundant sustainable energy Oh
probably everybody could agree on that
right except some energy companies in
Texas yes I think people would like to
have more of those things but figuring
out like you're always balancing one set
of goals against another so
err for everyone to breathe okay as long
as I get to pick who everyone is I'm
totally on board yes I think that those
were things are but like I was visiting
some I was on a work trip in India and I
was sort of stunned at one point by the
youth like they're just so many
two-stroke engines making use and they
just puff out yeah
such 10 minutes and I'm like well why
when people use four-stroke engines well
two-stroke engines are a lot more
reliable and they don't break down so
much and making repairs is very
expensive and hard to do with many of
the people couldn't afford missing even
a single day's work for the time to do
that the two-stroke the two-stroke
engines are less fuel efficient but fuel
is relatively inexpensive compared to
missing a day being out of work and it's
much more expensive to buy a four-stroke
engine to start with and so they the the
people weren't making crazy choices
their four-stroke engines were available
for tuk tuks you can get them most
people have chosen to strip ones because
it was it was the economic choice that
made sense in the moment and I think
that that's not like that's I I would
like to have government's be able to
help fix that problem like the
government's could you know wouldn't
just say ban two-stroke engines and then
say people have to starve because they
can't afford the four-stroke ones but
maybe help make those cheaper so that
people can have but I think that in fact
I think that's sort of what governments
are supposed to do but help people help
people help people make decisions that
benefit everyone I think those are the
things that we would like government to
do and of course you know I have
libertarian friends I live in Bay Area
who think that government always screws
that up so we shouldn't so we should
have US government I disagree I think
government is
been able to really help a lot of
problems definitely I agree with that
yeah without the first founding
documentation of government we would be
in a much different place as a country
how about we again we trying to stretch
you into a different zone what do you
think is going on with technology
exacerbating wealth inequality overall
the bottom line of people is coming up
slowly over time but we're experiencing
quite the different socio-economic
stratification that's going on what do
you think we're gonna do about that
wealth inequality gap so I don't know I
mean I I both I personally believe that
I think that technology is involved in
that but I don't I don't really have any
evidence to support this statement like
we tend to jump like I think part of it
is that we tend to jump up jump on
whatever works the best and so all other
things get pushed aside and so then all
the finances then coalesce into one
group so like Google Google makes tons
of money from advertising that's annex
to the expense of all the local things
that used to get the advertising money
in the past Oh
and so like local newspapers vanish
because there isn't as much advertising
revenue for the local because people are
saying well maybe if I advertising using
Google AdWords that will work better for
me or I'm you know like I can't quote
any studies to that effect at the moment
but it seems like that might be the case
and so I so I think that men sort of
this desire for the best and because
it's so easy to switch to jump on
whatever seems to be the best gives us
okay or creates the situation that a lot
of resources are going to be
concentrated in those single entities
and in the past we've worked something
with like creating standards bodies so
that lots of different people can
compete in the same feel
maybe that's the sort of solution that
we need to have hmm
we have blockchain coming up with
decentralization and distributed systems
it seems to be a good you know solution
as well to centralization okay question
about the cosmos do you think we're
alone there's no evidence there's anyone
else out there however I believe that
there must be the universe is quite
large it can't be this unlikely do you
think there are advanced civilizations
roaming the cosmos again I think that
the so I suspect yes the universe is
quite large I suspect they're they're
probably not like us like I think they
look like you I don't know I think I
would like I think that my own biases
are like you know what life is like you
know Star Trek used to say it's not it's
life but not as we know it except it
always was I think I'm afraid we would
like run across other life but not even
realize it was there it's so outside of
our perceptions of what it even freaking
animals and plants even times like we
just walk by them and don't realize that
they're still absorbing nutrients and
oxygen and and sunlight and yeah things
that live much faster or much slower
lives that are very like I have to say
distributed sort of thinking systems
those might all be very different for us
and we might not be able to recommend we
don't we barely even realize how
synchronised we are in our energies
right now sitting next to each other
engaging each other but when you look
underground at the root systems of trees
and of mycelium and these types of
plants it's just fun guys just wow how
are they doing that how are they
communicating like that okay do you
think we're in a computer simulation I
don't think we're in a computer
simulation but I'm I've read back and
forth different people trying to argue
whether or not you'd be able to tell and
Ian banks is one of my favorite writer
in in banks who talks about that as well
in his writing I'm not sure that I would
know one way or another
maybe the deja Vu's are a little hiccup
in the programming jeez could be could
be okay ever had Bouchard a explicable
feeling that you've never seen something
before when you know you should have Oh
like I have that every so often to like
I will pick up I'm missing the point in
my life where I like pick up a book I
know I read this book before and I start
reading and I'm like this should feel
like I should have more feeling about
what's happening in this book and I'm
like no I don't I don't recognize that
it's like did I not really read this
before like I'm sure I have it's on my
bookshelf it's got the pages uh here
mark where I like read it previously I'm
gonna let you keep that one there is
your own yeah I won't lose a day rate on
anyone's parade good one though it's a
good one hose yeah right okay last
question or maybe we can pair these
together possibly what do you what is
the deepest emotion you've ever felt I
mean
so I've had students at various times
over the years like suddenly get
something yeah and look in their faces
they suddenly understand something it's
uh it's not just being happy
it's fulfilling like the this day
everyone wants to move the ball forward
everyone wants to feel like that they're
making progress in the world making the
world better that sensation of like I
don't always know if I'm succeeding but
in that moment I have this feeling of
wow how'd it's really working that feels
really good
yeah the the mind being expanded to new
dimensions of thought and realization I
mean when they like I know that they are
seeing the world differently in that
moment and that arguably there's
probably no way to return to the way it
was before
yes yeah and that and and that is really
you know that's literally mind expanding
for us in a way that you know it's
really thrilling and then it helps
advance it moves the ball of
civilization forward how about a last
question what do you think is the most
beautiful thing in the world
well besides my wife I just sort of I'd
like to just lie down someplace where
it's not too cold and stare up at the
stars and see the Milky Way and just
watch the stars and the planets go by
yeah more us turn underneath them if you
will yeah but it's it has this sensation
of being both very far away and close at
the same time and we can't tell the
difference you can feel like you know
the beyond your reach but how much
farther it's hard to tell
yeah and all of their light beaming down
onto you all those stars I mean they
thought that something you know it's the
motion of charged particles hmm
hundreds of trillions of miles away
their motion it's causing the motion of
charged particles in your eye to move
and that's all that light is like that's
a disconcerning I'm beautiful it's so
cool yeah that's a good one I that
feeling is so ego dwarfing it feels so
great
Zeek Wow
what a pleasure this is really here
thank you for inviting me yeah this has
been such a pleasure we really
appreciate it
we've learned so much about the nature
of learning and about how to teach these
complicated subjects to kids and make
them fun make them engaged get them
excited about it and expand their minds
these new areas of thought and how
important it is to help support our
teachers help support our teachers yes
they need help too many stories of
teachers having to go and get their own
supplies or having too many kids in the
classroom having there's so many of
these stories let's work together on
figuring out how to make this better and
I think we can do that here in the US
and across the world and giving teachers
the right tools that they need and
giving the kids the right tools they
need especially things like computers
now in today's digital age like it's a
crucial aspect of their of their
learning
all right everyone thank you for tuning
in we greatly appreciate it if you had a
good time share this content
let's get other people talking about
this give us a comment below with your
thoughts and we'll feature you on our
Instagram and our Twitter let us know if
you if you want to join the team team
its simulation series at gmail.com let
us know we have tons of awesome
opportunities and internships waiting
also give us a subscribe if you want to
gently press the subscribe button if you
want to smash it let us know join the
team join the team subscribe subscribe
and join us on patreon we need to
sustain the space we need to sustain our
team join us let's expand let's get more
people in the creative studio let's get
it up to football stadiums let's do it
together and thanks for on Vargus are
producing partner and thank you guys for
tuning in we'll see you soon
[Music]
[Music]